good afternoon I'm Jeff bourbon the
United States Attorney for the Southern
District of New York today the ceilin
indictment charging left harness yegorov
rumen and two co-defendants to their
election and schemes to violate the
federal campaign finance laws by
repeatedly using straw donors and
foreign money
Karnas have proven were arrested around
6:00 p.m. last night at Dulles Airport
as they were about to board an
international flight with no way tickets
as alleged in the indictment the
defendants broke the law to gain
political influence while avoiding
disclosure of who's actually making the
donations that where the money was
coming from they saw political influence
not only to advance their own financial
interests but to advance the political
interests of at least one foreign
official a ukrainian government official
who sought the dismissal of the US
ambassador to ukraine and with respect
to that last allegation let me take you
through some of their money flows
harness and crewmen contributed $325,000
to committee 1 this contribution was not
made in their name
it was made in the name of the
corporation that they set up gep in
order to hide that the true individuals
behind the donation were harnessed and
proving the $325,000 for one of the
largest donations that committee 1
received and we in the indictment we
indicated allege that this was an
illegal straw donor scheme in addition
harness and Truman made direct
contributions to congressman one and
these contributions direct and promised
total over $20,000 moreover committee 1
spent approximately 3 million dollars to
benefit as congressman Warren now as a
result harness and Truman
had several meetings with congressman
one and at these meetings harness on
behalf of the Ukrainian government
officials lobby congressman one to
advocate for the removal of the then US
ambassador to Ukraine protecting the
integrity of our elections and
protecting our elections from unlawful
foreign influence our core functions of
our campaign finance laws and as this
office has made clear we will not
hesitate to investigate and prosecute
those who engage in criminal conduct
that draws into question the integrity
about political process and I want to
add that this investigation is
continuing now I want to acknowledge and
thank our wonderful 80 was a who worked
on prosecuting and investigating this
case that will continue to investigate
this case to my right is Rebecca dollar
Leske and someone who would ordinarily
be to her right Nick Rhodes could not be
here today because he is in the Eastern
District of Virginia
assisting with the presentment of
harness and treatment but to the
Rebecca's right is Rosco power and
Edward discount that they are marvelous
Co Chiefs of our public corruption unit
and I also want to thank our partner in
this case and so many of our important
cases the New York office of the FBI
represented here today to by laughs bill
Sweeney my good friend the assistant
director in charge of the New York field
office to his left
Mike Driscoll the special agent in
charge of the Criminal Division and to
his left
George Kazami the special agent in
charge of public
and now I'd like to invite to the podium
my very good friend go sweetie
thanks Jeffrey last night at Washington
Dulles International Airport the FBI
arrested Lemp Arness and Igor Froman on
campaign finance related charges as they
attempted to leave the United States
andrei Kukushkin was arrested in San
Francisco shortly thereafter David
Correia the fourth individual charged in
today's indictment is not yet in our
custody
campaign finance finance lawless exists
for a reason the American people expect
and deserve an election process that has
not been corrupted by the influence of
foreign interest and the public has a
right to know the true source of
campaign contributions walls make up the
fabric of who we are as a nation these
allegations are not about some
technicality a civil violation or an
error on a form this investigation is
about corrupt behavior deliberate
ball-breaking the FBI takes the
obligation to tackle corruption
seriously there are no exceptions to
this rule we gathered
you
district thank you as well to our FBI
personnel and her offices in Miami San
Francisco and Washington DC and of
course thanks might the gorge to your
team and the team of agents and
professionals who are quiet
professionals and solid public servants
here in the New York office thank you